every time you go through this Hardy's
drive-through you'll hear would you like
to try a peach pie for 159 nope would
you like to try a peach pie for 159 no
peach pie for 159. no thank you peach
pie no peach pie I have one peach pie no
peach pie that's because that's an AI
chatbot that now takes all the
drive-through orders at this Hardy's
location on Kent Island in Maryland well
unless the bot needs human help one
moment let me get a team member to help
you
and this Tech may be coming to a
restaurant near you made by a company
named Presto it's available at 350
locations in the country including
Carl's Jr Del Tacos and checkers it even
uses some of open ai's GPT Tech but how
does the tech work and is it really
taking over real jobs I designed three
challenges and drove through this drive
through about 30 times
thank you for choosing Hardy thank you
for choosing party
so find out how good this bot is at
feeding hungry humans challenge one
speech recognition the first thing
Presto does is use automatic speech
recognition to convert an order to text
so the AI system can understand it I'd
like the big hearty combo with extra
ketchup and a Diet Coke sure would you
like to make that a medium or a large
but as we all know from speech to text
on our phones sometimes it isn't perfect
especially with background noise which
there's typically a lot of at a drive
through initiate dog sounds
can I get the 10 piece chicken nuggets
what dipping sauce would you like
um what tipping sauces do you have Ranch
honey mustard barbecue sauce honey Cube
and hot or creamy buffalo sauce
oh to the honey mustard
um do you like dogs sure
okay but what about
I get a kid's meal
they're the two-piece chicken tenders
[Music]
and for the extreme Challenge what can
we get started for you today
[Music]
can you please speak louder so that I
may hear you
one big hearty with the Diet Coke please
one moment let me get a team member to
help you okay I'm not even sure a human
would hear me over that challenge one
pass challenge two natural language
processing once the system has that text
prompt it goes to the AI brain what's
called presto natural language
understanding the AI interprets The
Prompt and determines a follow-up
response would you like to make that a
medium or a large large would you like
to try a peach pie for 159 what drink
would you like Diet Coke and no to the
peach pie at this location Presto has
now Incorporated open ai's GPT into the
system to make the read back portion of
the order sound more human-like I have
one number for the big Hardy combo with
extra ketchup large fries and large Diet
Coke correct once the order is received
it's transferred to the restaurant's
kitchen display so a human can make and
package up the food for simple
straightforward orders it works well got
the order right
it's fairly efficient and yes there's
the upsell would you like to try a peach
pie I do not want the peach pie got it
it also did quite well when I changed my
order
um I'd like the big hearty combo
actually uh would you like medium or
large sorry sorry actually I'd like the
Superstar with cheese sure thing unlike
Chachi PT which is trained on a large
language model this system is trained on
a limited set of data including the
Restaurant's menu I'm gonna get two
spicy tuna rolls I'm sorry but that item
is currently unavailable you have a
pepperoni pizza no and it does fail at
some pretty simple tasks do you know how
many calories there are in the Western
bacon cheeseburger one moment let me get
a team member to help you I am allergic
to gluten is there gluten in that no
there's definitely gluten in that bread
can can I speak to a human one moment
please let me get someone to help you hi
I'm sorry about that we do have a
lettuce wrap Presto said this was an
error and then any allergy questions
should trigger the bot to get a human
challenge two I'm giving it a pass
because it did get most orders right but
yes it needs to work on the allergy
issue Challenge three humanness one of
the things I like about drive-throughs
or I'm say I like about drive-throughs
is talking to a human what's your
favorite Taylor Swift song what's your
favorite thing on the menu
say order when ready please if you are
free tonight
order when ready please
yeah but 3.3 million Americans are fast
food or counter workers making this a
very human-centric job do we really want
AI taking this job
yet here at the Hardee's on this 15 Mile
Island in Maryland AI hasn't taken jobs
at least not yet
we put Presto in to support our team
they're currently understaffed as in
most restaurants currently in the area
now that we have Presto our Frontline
Personnel are more free to do other
things like Drop fries assemble orders
tend to dining room guests make our
hand-dipped ice cream shakes make sure
that quality assurance in every level is
too standard we have no intention of
cutting labels and I was happy to hear
that given how very nice the humans at
the Hardys were and how unhumanlike the
bot was
so much
so what did we learn here today well
that this AI is very good at the basics
of drive-through order taking but like
most applications of AI right now this
is a way to help humans rather than
fully replace them a human still has to
babysit this spot
so typically this is where we would lock
in and take over but all I did was order
the big hearty yeah this is what would
scale was sometimes I apologize but of
course this Tech is only going to get
better and more companies will give in
to making AI part of their Workforce
just like I gave in to the peach pie on
a 100 degree day
with cream filling
she's too crazy
[Music]